let me talk about something interesting
I sometimes mention if you ever shop on
amazon.com there's a way in which your
shopping can support the work that we do
uh and the way to do that is by going to
david pakman.com slash amazon and then
you will be sent to amazon.com and any
shopping you do will send us a little
kickback the most expensive item of the
week purchased by our viewers over the
last seven days was a 454 dollar cargo
box for the roof of a car uh and it's
funny that this was an item because just
over the weekend uh I was driving back
to western Massachusetts and there was
just insane traffic on the mass turnpike
highway 90 which sometimes happens and
after something like an 18 or 20 minutes
slow down it turned out that one of
these cargo boxes had seemingly taken
flight off of the roof of a car and
exploded in the middle of the Turnpike
uh splitting in half and leaving up
clothing and all sorts of different
stuff all over the Turnpike and I I
wonder on some level if that was the box
purchased by a david pakman show viewer
at some point in the last week which
caused my traffic delay over the weekend
probably not but a coincidence
nonetheless and the most unusual item i
spot i spotted on the list of items
purchased through amazon over the last
week somebody bought 15 regular wired
phones the kind that mount on the wall
or sit on a desk the fact that somebody
bought so many of them it's unclear if
it's actually for like a really big
house or maybe for an office or more
likely for an art project because at
this point those wired phones are really
becoming relics of the past i I was
thinking how many people do I know for
whom I have a home number almost nobody
at this point uh although many many of
those people maybe have a home number
but they don't give it to anybody i have
not had a home number for a very very
long time I'd be curious to hear from
the audience do you still have what is
considered to be a landline um and and
why do you see yourself getting rid of
it remember david pakman.com slash
amazon
is the way to support the show with the
amazon shopping that you do